what's being generated over there in the
acid can all my word we're going to show
you something rather mininum today and
the thing is we've got here coke cans
and Pepsi cans as well
so that it's fair but when Neil gave
them to me I had to look inside and you
can see there this one has quite clearly
rusted so these coke cans are made of
aluminium whereas the Pepsi ones are
steel that's why we can only use the
coke cans to do this next experiment so
what we're going to do with these is to
show a property of aluminium and how it
reacts with both acid and with base and
that means it's a substance that's
amphoteric what we're going to do is
we've got a solution of sodium hydroxide
that's our base and we've got also
hydrochloric acid and then Neil's going
to put the acid in and I'll put the base
in at the same time and we're going to
see what happens to the aluminium cans
you go
oh yeah straightaway you can see the
bubbling there with the bass clearly a
very vigorous reaction in both cases so
what's being generated here is sodium
aluminate what's being generated over
there in the acid can all my word is
aluminium chloride and water we expected
reaction with both yet I hadn't
anticipated to be quite so vigorous I
hadn't expect it to be quite so Wow
that is brilliant so this is obviously a
very rigorous hot reaction you've got a
lot of fumes being given off which is a
good job we why we did it in the fume
cupboard you can see all that smoke
being drawn up into the extraction
family I honestly thought the acid would
have done more damage because when you
think of acid you always associate acids
as being these that you know the evil
guy of the year of the chemical world I
think those petty kinds have gotten off
very lightly they may have had their
tops cut off but they've met a fate far
better than the coke cans here good old
Pepsi for making them steel Neil can you
clean that for us what's left is just
the plastic around the outside of the
can all the metal has been converted to
sodium aluminate and that one's still
going the acid is still eating away at
that can and again it's just leaving
behind the plastic coating it was a
really experiment reaction and I didn't
think I would actually see a can
bubbling away like that
that is just incredible isn't it it is
pretty disgusting